obviously X months of restarted this
resurgence of superhero films in the
cinema how do you feel about the way
that the dominate in the box-office now
feel about it I think it's great I think
it's great because right now we're at a
time in superhero movies where the this
there's such diversity there's women
leading movies there's Black Panther the
first Asian superhero movie is being
written and that's something that is
just really exciting to be a part of and
what about for you Jessica what made you
want to be part of a superhero film I
just want to be a part of every genre
you know I like the spectacle of these
films and I mean I probably wouldn't
want to do a contract that meant that I
was gonna be doing only these films for
the next 20 years but I can tell you I
really like coming in and and being with
everyone and doing all the action and
the special effects and it really feel
like your honor in an amusement park and
in some sense you know and it's fun and
obviously I can tell from your social
media a big game of Thrones fun so how
was it working with someone who was
obviously on it was on the show we
trying to get secrets if you know what
was happening in the script no actually
I wasn't getting secrets but sometimes I
would say something and I'd be like this
is what's gonna happen don't look at me
because I'll be able to tell from your
face I was just I was terrified that
like like the first three seasons of
that show beloved characters were
murdered in cold blood and I was going
to burn it to the ground sound like
Daenerys yes they yeah I would have
would have avenged you for sure thanks
girl of course how do you feel so good
you feel like it's a weight off your
shoulders now you can obviously talk
about it to keep everything so under
wraps so that that's really enjoyable
but now I miss it
you know as soon as you as soon as it
finishes now Mike I wish I was still
keeping those secrets I wish I was
had snipers at my head HBO snipers is
that it for you now if they every was a
spin-off film or anything would you what
would be keen to reprise that role I
think it's time to say goodbye to Sansa
I'm ready
ish it's a say goodbye Tower I think you
know my watch has ended oh yeah I just
think you know it's been 10 years of my
life in the best 10 years of my life by
far and I I'm just I finished in a very
happy place with answerin and it's time
to let go I feel like if I played her
again it would just be more drama